في تطور هو الاول من نوعه منذ بدء استهداف
مواقع ومصالح امريكيه بالشرق الاوسط بعد
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه اعلنت واشنطن
مقتل ثلاثه عسكريين امريكيين واصابه اخرين
بهجوم بطائره مسيره قالت انها استهدفت
القوات الامريكيه شمال شرقي الاردن قرب
الحدود مع سوريا وقال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن في بيان ان الهجوم نفذته جماعات
متشدده مدعومه من ايران تعمل في سوريا
والعراق واضاف ان ادارته تجمع المعلومات
عن هذا الهجوم وان قلب امريكا مثقل بمقتل
جنودها واكد بايدن في بيانه ان واشنطن
ستحاسب كل المسؤولين عن هذا الحادث
وبالطريقه التي تختارها وانها ستحافظ على
الالتزام المقدس تجاه عائلات الضحايا
وبمكافحة
تعبير
البيان لقد مررنا بيوم صعب فليله الماضيه
فقدنا ثلاثه جنود شجعان في هجوم على احدى
قواعدنا في الشرق الاوسط اطلب دقيقه صمت
على ارواح هؤلاء الجنود الثلاثه الذين
سقطوا
وسنرد